[Music]
you're getting to do a lot of really
cool things like go to the SAG Awards
which i think is fun you get to meet
different other celebrities that you
might be interested in seeing
yeah I'm sure Bob with celebrities you
babble celebrities yeah just like most
of the time I just fooled to my feet and
just like uh everything to me yeah
you've been so calm here anyway you know
yeah I know I know I was kidding
but sometimes the game of the game of
Thrones Castle get seated a table and
then you'll be near a cool table you
were near a pretty cool table I think at
the SAG Awards weren't you are one of
those for the Golden Globes one of those
it was it was the sags and I was right
on the table next to it was like Ryan
Gosling Christian Bale and Steve Carell
that's a good table it was a good table
for that right so I was like yeah it's
really heavy hitches and so I was like
sat then Steve like Steve's back was
like right to me adorable
and and then I'm like a huge iron come
on fun so it's just kind of sat begging
like I love lamb you're doing his little
his line yeah thinking like that won't
be annoying yeah I love lamb yeah you
turn around no nevermind don't we have a
picture I think this is you with a
picture of you with Ryan Gosling that
photo brings me so much joy yes I'm
terrified that I'm gonna meet him though
one day and he's gonna be like I saw the
photo oh no he'd be charmed
you